je pense que vous devriez traiter les
gens comme vous voudriez qui vous
traitent ces pages et du caddie ça c est
de toujours accepté une faveur plutôt
que de l'argent
je pense que jésus a dit ça aussi enfin
parce qu'un passeur pour la deuxième et
la première c'est peut-être de lui ai
dit tu m'as tu seras reste derrière son
bureau
je suis sur le terrain que des mecs qui
bossent quoi je suis pharmacie des c'est
moi qui mène le jeu on ne peut pas dire
qu'il avait un corps de rêve et il avait
cette espèce de coiffure plutôt
recherchée pour cacher sa calvitie
mais c'est son assurance qui m'attirait
vers l'est mon père sait mais qui m'a
appris à croire que les gens sont bons
il faut être beau et les gens la vie
ridicule tu sais que je dirai jamais
rien demain sur ton père devant toi mon
chéri mais faut reconnaître que c'est un
sale fils de [ __ ]
papa est un sale fils de [ __ ] répète pas
mais oui
choteau rôle hockey est roi julien
tu as déjà dû trouver un moyen de
survivre tout en sachant que tes choix
n'étaient pas les bons mais qu'il
fallait bien survivre si on a toujours
réussi pendant si longtemps c'est parce
qu'on a su rester suffisamment petit
site a si bien réussi des coups pourquoi
tu te retrouves là dans cette pièce avec
moi à suivre les autres que moi je te
donne
ici l'agent dinozzo gmi 75000 dollars
dans cette mallette pour le maire carmen
collé tout
ce que tu fous presse
faut qu'on arrive à entuber tous ces
gars là on ne doit penser qu'à ça à
partir de maintenant réussir à entuber
tous ces gars ce sera meilleur coup
qu'on n'ait jamais faire